welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and while Loki season 2 promises us a
ton of surprises as it explains just
what new hellscape Loki was dropped into
at the end of the first season there was
one mystery involving Loki That season
2's time traveling Shenanigans May yet
come forward to solve the mystery of
Loki's mother because as of this point
we have yet to discover just who in the
MCU touched a cold dingaling that was
blue to make a Loki and Sylvie to well
how would you feel if I told you that
we've already met Loki's mom in the MCU
and that that mother is none other than
the goddess of death and enthusiastic
dog owner hella of Asgard well hella of
hell now she got kicked out would you
think that I was absolutely insane well
if you stick around my beautiful nerd
babies I'll tell you how this might not
be so unreasonable and that Loki could
legitimately be one of Odin's son with a
claim to the throne technically but
first do not forget to hit up new
roxasmerch.com to buy one of our amazing
new nerd options over there we got tons
of shirts pins stickers they'll hit up
new roxasmarch.com today alright so
first of all I get it okay you're
probably like what the hell are you
talking about Mt Thor Ragnarok clearly
established that hella is the older
sister of both Thor and Loki so like how
the hell would hella be Loki's mom and
you know what I get it man it's a bold
claim but I think this actually could be
possible and something that could end up
being revealed in Loki season 2 as Loki
travels throughout time and the main
reason why I believe the goddess of
death is the mother of Mischief lies
within an important Revelation made in
Thor Ragnarok specifically when hella
arrives back home to the Asgardian Royal
Palace and reveals to Scourge asgard's
true bloody history of Conquest when
hella and Odin conquered the nine Realms
side by side as father and daughter and
everything was great and cool until
hella decided that Conquering the nine
Realms just wasn't enough One By One The
Realms became ours but then simply
because my ambition outgrew his he
banished me caged me locked me away like
an animal and hella's pension for war
was of course something that Odin warned
his sons of mere moments before he dies
when he reveals to them the secret of
their Sinister sibling in the shadows it
is this very violent appetite that we're
going to be talking about today because
I believe that it's the main reason why
Loki was even born because it sounds
like from these retellings that hella
got super annoyed when Odin stopped
conquering Realms and even says as much
when she first arrives in Asgard we were
once the seat of absolute power in the
cosmos our Supremacy was unchallenged
yet Odin stopped at nine realms our
destiny is to rule over all others and
so hella tries to Stage a revolt against
Asgard and attempts to usurp the throne
from her soft ass father Odin but if you
notice from the Thor movies the people
of Asgard especially the armies of
Asgard hold unwavering loyalty to their
King I mean hell the Valkyries all
pretty much fell in Hell attacking Halo
for the big fella so this jealous hella
had a dilemma alright guys I'm on camera
a lot so I have to see my face a lot so
you'd think I'd have to put a lot of
effort into my skincare routine but I
don't because I use geology geology is a
15-time award-winning personalized skin
care company recognized in hypebeast
birdie Men's Health Esquire and ask man
grooming Awards with over 6 000 5 Star
reviews that is a lot of thousands
that's six of them and they've recently
expanded to offer products for pretty
much whatever you need all you've got to
do is take a quick 30 second diagnostic
quiz and geology figures out your
routine for you if you need hair care
now not me use geology's co-wash a
specially formulated cream cleanser that
removes buildup and cleanses the hair
without the big lather or harsh
ingredients of typical shampoo and for
the rest of your shower routine you can
use their body washes that are free of
harsh ingredients smell great and are
refillable and for after the shower
protect your skin from environmental
stressors with vitamin c and e for Rolex
serum to keep your skin looking young
and healthy and then a bit of
dermatologist tested aluminum-free
deodorant that quite honestly smells
great like I've gotten so many
compliments from the ladies specifically
so and right now for a limited time
geology is hooking our audience up with
an absolutely insane insanity if you use
code new rockstars they will give you an
additional 70 off their award-winning
skin care trial set that's seven zero
percent seventy that discount applies
whether you're stocking up for yourself
or stuffing someone else's stocking
instead either way geology has you
covered check out their awesome gift
sets featuring all your favorite geology
products to get started just click the
link in the description take a 30 second
diagnostic quiz and their team of
dermatologists will design a person
routine just for you that shifts
directly to your door so in order for
Helen to actually stand a chance rising
up against her father the goddess of
death would have to forge a secret
alliance with one of the other Realms
that she and Odin had forcefully gotten
to bend the knee the frost Giants of
yotenheit led by one Frost King laufi
who as we learned from the first Thor
movie clearly has no love for the
Asgardian rule of the cosmos so hella
enters an alliance with the frost Giants
and I think you know where I'm headed
with this one
hella gets bored one night and asked the
frost King to uh Shake That Frosty laffy
toffee as she put it I was there she
said that verbatim and he says okie
dokie and they do the pokey pokey and a
little later out comes Loki half-assed
guardian and half Frost Giant and hella
being the warmonger that she's always
been likely could not care any less for
the spawn that she just created during
that week one night stand with someone
she didn't actually like weak and she
had a war with Odin device so she likely
just left
and didn't look back like the absolute
Savage that she was but then that very
Savage hella got locked the [ __ ] up
after Odin muted her Mutiny and was
forced to deal with the frost giant
Uprising that she started once more
which eventually leads Odin to defeating
the frost Giants after they attempted to
take over midgard taking the casket of
ancient Winters which was the source of
gutenheim's frost power and of course
finding the baby that his rebellious
daughter made with his greatest enemy
fatherhood am I right I mean it happens
the kids have that rebellious stage
every time and sleep with your greatest
enemy ayla's oldest time and this would
all make sense to me especially
considering that a Odin always treated
Loki and Thor like his actual sons and B
Odin told Loki in the first film that he
hoped that Loki's existence would help
bring lasting peace between the two
realms I thought we could unite our
kingdoms one day bring about an alliance
bring about a permanent peace through
you
as plans no longer matter this would
make sense if Loki will legitimately
half as guardian from his mother hella's
side because he would be the first child
born of the two Realms with a rightful
claim to the throne and this would also
serve to explain why Sylvie knew that
she was adopted from a young age in her
Universe because if you think about it
Odin probably told her right away
because you know up until King Valkyrie
Asgard had never really seen a female
ruler so an Odin Bound by sexist
tradition probably didn't really see
Sylvie as an option to broker that piece
and he just told her the truth he was
like all right you're not really going
to be anything that I can use so here
you go it sucks but that's just that's
just the sexism of tradition I don't
know luckily Thor made that right by
making Valkyrie the king but yeah that
is how I believe Marvel will tell us how
Loki came to be in either Loki season 2
or a future Thor film and it would
definitely serve to explain Loki's
chaotic nature as she would come
directly from the chaotic hella as well
as his ability to switch between both
Asgardian and frost giant forms of ease
but anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
mastertamed on Twitter if you want to
see me tweet some weird [ __ ] but most
importantly you could fall into
rockstars wherever we are on the social
media but again thank you guys so so so
much for spending time with me I always
appreciate it and I'll see you guys next
time goodbye
[Music]
thank you